he was out there you know he eliminated
AP African-American studies he said
slavery was somehow some Workforce
Development program Gavin Nome who is
the uh governor of the failed State of
California he went on Seth Meyers late
night show does anyone watch this show
does who watch does Seth Meyer's mother
watch this show nobody watches this
thing but they keep trotting out these
horrible people to tell you that of
course it's the Republicans notably that
guy from Florida who are the real
racists when you started planning this
did you have higher expectations for
where Dan santis would be in the polls
no I didn't I'll be honest with you I've
and and I'm dead serious about this I
I've I've developed a lot of animus
towards him because of his animus
towards all of you um you know this
guy's out there scapegoating vulnerable
communities uh he's attacking uh
minorities attacking women and I don't
like it and I wanted to push back
against it and I felt like the party was
a little timid on all this I mean you
know he's out there talking about
anti-woke and I mean this it's for me
it's not anti-woke what he really means
is antiblack he's out there censoring
historic facts he's rewriting history uh
he was out there you know he eliminated
AP African-American studies he said
slavery was somehow some Workforce
Development program and he doubled down
on that so for me it's a very serious
moment where I just felt it was
important to blow back against that
against that narrative uh and hold these
guys accountable on a network where they
don't hear from guys like me
ever uh you're on that Network all the
time you're good buddies with Shan
Hannity he says it all the time so
that's a lie of course everything else
he said was a lie we'll just do it quick
is DeSantis attacking minorities and
women I was at Whole Foods yesterday
almost half the people there were women
I didn't see anyone attacked I saw some
minorities also everybody seemed to be
doing fine buying fruit in the in the
ice cream section everybody was there
it's okay the African-American studies
thing as you guys know that is a
complete lie the curriculum was written
by several black people acknowledging
that some black people might have
learned some skills like becoming a
blacksmith isn't isn't endorsing slavery
it's just actually a fact um and the
reason that they kick the co the course
out of Florida was because they combined
African-American studies with gender
queer stuff and these things have
nothing to do with each other unless
you're in intersectional
brainlet